I applied for this opportunity because  it was clearly a very unique opportunity  but also on top of that it was a  continuation of work that I'd done from  a few years ago which is looking into  the sensory components of indigenous  wisdom and that's in both practice and  in design and what we can learn from  that both in a kind of a more general  modern-day context and then also  specifically thinking about  multi-sensory immersive experiences I am  observing and collecting on the embodied  experience of worshiping a Shinto shrine  and looking at everything from that the  layout of them to the olfactory  experience of walking through them or to  wind measurements to humidity  measurements taking infrasonic readings  just looking at how the senses are  engaged by worshipers when they visit  these shrines  you